[Music]
in 1895
ogden bolton jr registered one of the
first patents for an electric bicycle in
the u.s
a century later they've become one of
the most popular electric vehicles in
the world
using electricity to enhance performance
the e-bike is definitely in the current
these electric three-wheel trikes
combine ergonomic design
with cutting-edge mechanical engineering
a rechargeable battery powers the
electric engine
the rider sits comfortably in the
ergonomic seat
places his feet on the pedals releases
the parking brake
and takes off
the process begins with a water jet
cutter it uses
ultra high pressure water and sand to
cut parts out of a thin
aluminum sheet the cutter significantly
enhances productivity
without sacrificing precision it can
make several parts out of a single sheet
of aluminum
parts that are ready for assembly go to
the cnc brake press for folding
a stopper positions the piece on the
v-die where a punch comes down to fold
it
a worker inspects the folded part to
make sure it's ready for assembly
a cnc bender curves aluminum extrusion
tubes for the frame
this machine has multi-directional
bending capabilities
and can make multiple bends to a single
extrusion tube
the trach frame assembly process starts
on a jig
once all the tubes are in place a welder
spot welds the aluminum brackets
he welds about 20 spots binding the
brackets to the tubes
the tubes bear most of the load while
the brackets keep the frame aligned
[Music]
the worker uses an electric tig welding
torch to complete the welding
he welds at a low temperature to avoid
heat deformation in the metal
[Music]
a mechanic installs thermo-formed
recyclable abs plastic
over the back frame tubes
he assembles the rear wheels which have
a 7 degree negative camber angle
for better grip and handling
the mechanic mounts brake levers gear
shifters and handle grips onto the
steering bar
and tightens the six-point socket nuts
with an allen wrench
[Music]
he applies a structural adhesive on the
dropout poles
and in slots located on the front frame
tubes
the adhesive provides the flexibility
and strength needed
to keep the dropout poles in position
now the mechanic assembles the front and
back frames together
the two frames connect under the seat
through an integrated direction pivot
and suspension system
the mechanic slips the front wheel into
the dropout poles on the frame
he uses a calibrated torque wrench to
tighten the wheel nut
he assembles the three cog front
cassette to the bottom bracket
then bolts on the pedal crank arm using
a threaded taper pin system
next he installs the derailleur for the
nine gear cassette
and bolts it on with a loctite bolt
[Music]
the compact drivetrain makes the trike
15
more energy efficient than regular
bicycles or tricycles
a mechanic installs the disc brake
system on the front wheel electric hub
and verifies that it is functioning
properly
the seats are made of woven synthetic
fabric wrapped around the frame and
tightened with bungee elastics
[Music]
he locks the removable battery pack in
place with a key
a console indicates levels of electrical
assistance and battery regeneration
this trike's wheelbase allows it to ride
on bike paths
when on the road its width takes up more
space
the design of this electric trike
combines stability and safety
for a secure and pleasant ride
you